we see a number of examples in
Washington about the use of political
intelligence how dangerous is the
practice of political intelligence in
your mind it's an area concern to say
it's dangerous it's an area we have to
look at an area we're looking at it's an
area which is enough in our areas now
it's an it's kind of another area where
influence is being could be it could be
it could not be but it's an area that
there's potential there for that to
happen potential for what though for
insider information because you know
there's laws certain laws that passed
could also affect businesses and that
could be great information for somebody
that can have that information to invest
in a certain company that may benefit
from the law so that's just another
another gray area that could be
potential fraud involved in you know I
mean hey I have to say when it comes to
these crooks specially white-collar
criminals they're creative they are
always looking for the edge that could
be another area where people gain unfair
edge yeah the question then those whose
cooperating with them that's that's not
that's not job to find out do you think
we'll see a lawmaker go to jail um I
could tell you if a lawmakers involved
in illegal insider trading type
activities yeah they should go to jail
if that's happening